a starry night in Hollywood that gave us
Glitz glamor and a moment that had
everybody doing a double take welcome
everyone to Entertainment Tonight and
speaking of double takes yes Rachel
Smith is here right here with me in LA
and where's Kevin Frazier well he's in
New York what's up Kev oh I'm hanging
here in New York we did a little
Switcheroo but I'll be here all day
ladies all night
it's not a Freaky Friday switch it's a
manic Monday exactly I'm gonna check in
with Kevin in just a little bit but
let's get back to that A-list crowd at
the Academy Museum Gala uh it was a good
one Michelle starting with the Clooney's
Holden Fashion Court our Cassie de Laura
was there
a mall in a strapless mint green gown
grab George's hand as he guided her past
photox
[Applause]
the leading man kept it classic in
Armani
and joked about icon Award winner Julia
Roberts George how proud are you of
Julia
Julia also suited up Miss Robert
Straight Ahead dazzling the crowd in
this custom Tom Brown corset dress you
know Eddie's very excited about Julia
Roberts being here we were doing press
yesterday and someone said what is your
favorite ending of a movie and then he's
like Pretty Woman welcome the Hollywood
what's your dream oh my goodness it is
is this trumpet to Hollywood what's your
dream another big headline Haley Bieber
and Selena Gomez putting an end to Feud
rumors it's all respect it's all love
that's Justin's wife and his ex smiling
cheek to cheek posing for pics together
17 days after Haley addressed rumors of
a Justin dating overlap were you ever
with Justin
romantically at the same time as her no
not not one time the reason we were able
to get back together was because it was
very much completely closed a source
tells E.T they wanted to show the world
that there's no beef or bad feelings
between them anymore Justin's take what
do you mean we're told Justin is very
happy with the fact that they can all
move on and that it can be peaceful
between everyone
[Music]
of course from Kerry Washington to Selma
Blair this event Was A Who's Who of
stars it was also a mini top gun
Maverick reunion Jay Ellis is here where
is he he's over there he's over there
Jay I'll ask my brother
as for the fashion there was a lot to
love Jessica Chastain stunning this
floral Oscar de la Renta Emma Stone
rocked a 1920s Vibe by Louis Vuitton
Cindy Crawford's look-alike daughter
Kaia Gerber sparkled like a super Chic
mermaid
our favorite couples Joe Jonas and
Sophie Turner were eclectic with Louis
Vuitton and keeping it classic Brooklyn
Beckham and his wife Nicola Peltz both
in jivashi
[Music]
thank you